du suspense des larmes un temps
splendide tous les ingrédients étaient
réunis sur sept golfeurs ce 2021
saint-jean mansle et ces championnats de
france amateurs de première division
dames était organisé du 13 au 17 octobre
sur les greens dessiné par l'architecte
de golf harry colts c'est la septième
fois que le site accueille l'épreuve le
parcours de saint germain s'adapte
parfaitement au jeu féminin il est un
petit peu trop court pour les grands
joueurs éventuellement de gaulle who
mais nous serons toujours favorable à
recevoir ce sept trophées ce trophée à
saint germain
cette 87e édition a attiré 16 des
meilleures équipes de france dont des
club yvelinois comme le racing club de
france saint germain en laye ou encore
sans nom la bretèche c'est un événement
qu'on attend tout à chaque pas parce que
c'est une compétition par équipe et
jouer pour son club et avec son club
c'est toujours génial en plus le fait de
jouer à saint germain cette année et
encore plus de monde qui peut venir nous
suivre donc c'est assez particulier
après cinq jours de compétition c'est
finalement saint nom la bretèche qui
remporte l'épreuve en battant toulouse
en finale son dernier succès remontait à
2002 au total le club yvelinois remporté
la gaule force pour la 19e fois de son
histoire c'est une surprise cette année
parce qu'on a quand même une équipe
relativement faible par rapport aux
autres et au final on a su s'accrocher
on a fait en adopter une bonne stratégie
qu'on respecte depuis le début de la
semaine le club remettra son titre en
jeu l'année prochaine avec un objectif
ramené une nouvelle fois la coupe à la
maison